the tweets are in dawn of the designer
baby
scientists safely used gene editing to
delete a mutation from a human embryo
bringing back ethical debates scientists
have edited human embryos to safely
remove diseases what could go wrong
great question
Trump is the designer baby of the GOP
good point
stoked for those who may benefit but
scared this might be the beginning of
the end of the era of smart monkeys who
you callin a monkey
last week the MIT Technology Review
reported that scientists in Oregon
successfully modified the DNA of human
embryos using the gene editing technique
CRISPR to edit out a heritable heart
condition signaling perhaps the dawn of
designer babies start saving your
pennies or you might wind up with one of
those outdated imperfect babies plus
roaming millennial Amanda presto Giacomo
and Paul Bois joined the panel of
deplorable x' to discuss Rosie
O'Donnell's new women only political
party White House aide Stephen Miller's
Smackdown of CNN and the prospect of
president Zuckerberg oh my stick around
at the end because I will answer your
questions from our first ever mailbag
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Music]
as is a major news story that scientists
have now successfully edited the human
genome and deleted a mutation for a
heart disorder which is called
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy luckily we
at the Michel null ship we have so many
great live feeds we have a live feed
from the laboratory where this advance
occurred can we cut to it genetics what
could it mean the ability to perfect the
physical and mental characteristics of
every unborn child in months oh no that
was that was the trailer for the 1997
sci-fi epic Gattaca that was not only we
got to fix that life II say it's a very
good movie
now of course left-wing outlets
predictably are denying that this is the
age of Gattaca they're denying even not
only the moral hazard but even that this
is happening in the first place the
Atlantic has a big piece at today quote
the designer baby era is not upon us
American scientists have now used CRISPR
to edit embryos doesn't mean we're
entering into Gattaca dystopia steven
pinker out of harvard has been denying
that this is happening for a decade now
he wrote 10 years ago 15 years ago I
think the prospect of designer babies is
very much in doubt we can deal with the
ethical conundrums if and when they
arise but thinkers should acknowledge
the frailty of technological predictions
and based policy recommendations on
likelihoods rather than fantasies but
not all of the experts agree not even
all of the experts on the left agree
there is a left-wing pro-abortion
genetic study Center it's called the
Center for genetics and society and and
they're firmly against this they're
saying that what's being reported as
research here is deeply misleading and
quote there's no need to manipulate the
genes of children to remove the risk of
disease so in this debate it's very
confusing let's turn to the foremost
expert we have in channeling scientific
technology to perfect human nature get
out it's even mudhole body
Roxie's on right rooms at Dells essence
see boy painted on top the event control
sputters earning with license see ya
I'm Tommy Marshall how many times do I
have to tell you I don't speak German
we don't all speak German okay now we're
lucky that we also have an
english-speaking analyst I guess we'll
have to listen to him on this
it's an expert out of the university of
chicago leon kass he's a brilliant
humanist he was also the chairman of
President Bush's presidential Council on
bioethics
inquiry and he breaks down this issue a
little more in depth for those of us who
could speak not see most of us
cheerfully believe that we can both
enjoy the promise and escape the perils
of the coming biotechnological age most
of us also believe that there is little
connection between the promise and the
peril or between the humanistic
aspirations that fuel the scientific
enterprise and the deadly or
dehumanizing uses to which new
technologies might perversely be put but
a powerful challenge to our complacent
opinion is provided by an important
exhibit prepared by the United States
Holocaust Museum entitled deadly
medicine creating the master race this
exhibit documents the abominable uses
that the Nazis made of science and
medicine but even more relevant for us
it also presents the scientific outlook
on life and the aspiration to human
perfectibility that the Nazis inherited
and Exploited an outlook and an
aspiration that dwell robustly in
American cultural life today yeah well I
certainly understood it better from leon
kass and and i think that's why I'm
always reluctant to make comparisons to
the Nazis but I don't think it's that a
place here because this is a disturbing
trend that's happened for a while but it
is a break from Western civilization the
quest to perfect human nature
scientifically and not merely socially
you know it was put I don't remember who
put it this way but it was put that
previously in Western civilization we
had a god made man who saved us from sin
through his suffering and now we have
man-made God who is saving us himself
from the sin of suffering that is a
really radically different way of
approaching our lives in approaching the
world and it raises a number of ethical
questions that we have not even come
close to answering yet and probably we
should answer before we start creating
these supermen these little super babies
will designer babies create radical
inequality if if we can we're already
selecting out through abortion the
people who have mental illnesses or who
are mentally [ __ ] while they're
still in the womb they're the number of
people with Down syndrome is decrease
dramatically because people are
selecting against it there there is this
radical inequality that could be created
and there's also the question of who has
access to it so if this technology
exists to get rid of certain heritable
diseases or to augment intelligence or
so on and so forth who's going to have
access to them it's going to be people
who have the money to pay for it and now
even if this is highly regulated by the
government of course a black market will
exist and when we're talking about
something as important and fundamental
as human nature and as the human brain
that black market could breed a lot of
chaos and trouble some other questions
are the unintended consequences do we
really want to unbound ourselves from
our human nature and when I say that
this technology has the prospect to
change human nature I'm not speaking
hyperbolically the word nature is is
referring to how we are born how humans
are born into this world so if we can
eliminate suffering and early death or
disease or what have you would we really
want to suffering and enriching an
inherent part of the human condition and
if we say well we'll just get rid of the
really bad diseases how do we determine
what these really bad diseases are this
heritable heart condition that affects
athletes that we've selected against or
edited out using this technology is is
that the threshold or certain other
diseases I need a lot is that it will
that someday be edited out I joke a
little bit but it's really hard to draw
that line and also does this affect the
commoditization of life you know we've
we've seen that life you know can have a
money value in the modern world and life
that's more costly to create will have a
higher price tag on it do we want a
further
life in the material world and does it
doesn't undermine concepts that are
essential to our country in our
civilization Universal equality quality
before God all men are created equal and
have natural rights will we create men
intentionally who are decidedly unequal
who have huge variability in IQ or
resistance to disease or so on and so
forth and there's a generational ethical
question which is you're not only
affecting the genome for one person
you're affecting it all the way down the
line if you're taking out heritable
diseases then his children will not
inherit them and his children and his
children and so forth and who gets to
make that call you know I think it's to
make that call our panel of deplorable
z-- we bring on roaming millennial you
know her from the youtubes
with The Daily wires very unamended
Presta Giacomo and for some reason pol
blah the voice of the Lord Himself
roaming does this mean that one day we
could even make an embryo that was
destined to look like paul bois end up
looking like you or Amanda because then
very possibly I could get on board with
it yeah you know this is an issue where
honestly I'm sworn I mean you know
obviously when we start talking about
steps to perfect the human race I mean
yeah that is you know not see whispers
kind of start going off the back of your
head but Paul's nickname in high school
by the way was a Nazi I'm sorry to
interrupt go ahead that's a good one
well I mean yeah you know at the same
time people are saying like hey look we
have the chance of eradicating a lot of
these more serious diseases and you know
as someone who hopes to be a mother
someday I'm trying to put myself in that
position or like if I'm about to have a
kid and you know this is a possibility I
can ensure that they are going to be
healthy growing up it's if they're
really honestly it's a hard decision to
make and I think it's something that you
know we add as a public should have more
input on right I don't think we should
just you know let this happen and kind
of on the sidelines like I'm looking
into it I think this right exactly I
think we do need be having this
conversation as a culture because like
you said there's a ton of implications
that we've never had to deal with before
and you bring up a great point I think
everybody wants it for their child I
want it for a little little my colinear
for sure I just don't want it for anyone
else's child and and this raises the
moral this moral hazards
Paul to you moral hazards moral hazard
why shouldn't we just make our kids
pretty and smart and wonderful I mean
well we can go on all day about what
kind of world this opens up I think the
movie Gattaca really successfully
explored the kind of caste system that
would develop with genetically enhanced
human beings but I think an interesting
point is one that was made by dr. David
King when he said that by genetically
enhancing people we would therefore be
forcing them to perform according to the
way that we designed them to so
essentially we're eliminating people's
free will so let's take for example you
a do you take a person who's born and we
designed them to be like ben shapiro
a superhuman you know I forgive it no
Lots for a god help let us say this this
ben shapiro clone he just decides one
day he wants to sit all day on his butt
and watch Brady Bunch who's to say that
governments or an agency can't force him
to live according to the way that he was
designed to do so so that's that's an
interesting point I think we just got a
window into poll Saturday afternoons
just sitting on that couch watching the
Brady sounds good to me
Amanda the secular left is always
harping on inequality they imagine
inequalities they create new
inequalities but they seem to be
embracing this at least a good
percentage of them isn't there a
disconnect here yeah and you see the
same thing and abortion as you were
talking about earlier it's the same
thing where they're eliminating Down
syndrome babies like they talk about all
this inequality income inequality that's
what they're fixated on when it comes to
things like this we are literally
eliminating Down syndrome children
through abortion and again this would be
the same thing where you would eliminate
whatever quality or whatever I mean I
know they're talking about genetic uses
right now but you know where does this
Borden's this end and all in the name of
penalization isn't it just like the
compassion to let little chat as always
as always I same with abortion of
compassion for the mother but no
compassion for the child and again like
Paul said no free will as well that's a
great point roaming Leon compared this
to to the Holocaust to compare
not the eugenics is that or is that
outrageous it were the Nazi eugenics a
bastardization of science or is it the
logical conclusion of this sort of
scientific inquiry well I mean if we if
we take the assumption that there are
groups that we are as a society
prejudiced against I I don't know let's
say let's say Ginger's because that's a
pretty inoffensive way to go it's not
crazy to think that when we have to
believe this man Richard Spencer back
here again with all her racist glance
I'm sorry go ahead rummy but you know
how crazy to think that when we do have
the ability to select which genes in
which traits we want to pass on to our
children that these traits that we find
less desirable will be eliminated from
the gene pool and you know if you're you
know if you're someone who is I don't
know of a you know let's say again let's
go with gingers that's April a ginger
thread I mean I don't think it's crazy
to make that leech and say like hey yeah
you know maybe this is something we
should be concerned about do we want to
give people the power to you know kind
of take these genes out of out of our
society out of humans based on I don't
know it answers of course yes we're
probably going to get blunders YouTube
for all of the Santi ginger talk a
person is a lot of control to be giving
some people to scientists absolutely
absolutely and Paul you're the more
Catholic than the Pope would you say
that people here are looking now towards
science for their salvation questions
that they might have prayed for or
accepted suffering with acceptance and
patience they're now looking for science
to fix is there something wrong with
this is it going on do about it oh
absolutely
Michael there's a tons of things all
wrong with here so I mean what you have
here is really it's a multi-pronged
situation with different theological
implications like one is a constable
good you know which is the healing of
certain diseases while the other is a
violation of natural law and that's the
enhancement of humans beyond their
natural state and so the church makes a
clear distinction between genetic
enhancement and genetic therapy genetic
therapy essentially restores nature I
mean as long as it restores the dignity
upon a person
and genetic enhancements imposes upon
them something that wasn't there already
naturally you know you make them super
smart or you make them super athletic
and that is very clearly defined as
morally defunct and to be avoided an
important distinction from Cardinal Bois
we have to move on the d-triple-c the
Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee has signaled that there will
be no litmus test for candidates just
speaking of eugenics they are suggesting
that they'll allow pro-life democrats to
run and still fund them Rosie O'Donnell
is very upset about this she is
threatening to form her own all women
political party if the Democrats don't
kick out all of the pro-lifers from
their party for reaction we go to
President Trump well Rosie O'Donnell is
disgusting I mean both inside matter
Rosie a very personally because I was
very happy when her talk show failed the
other thing that failed and this was a
real monster
and everybody was suing her maybe her
party will fail to Amanda it fair to say
that Rosie O'Donnell will never need an
abortion why does she care about this
summer
um yeah she first of all I'm just I'm
glad that she's speaking up and coming
to the forefront of a Democratic Party
is much better out there I'm close it
makes Lena Dunham look separable so I'm
okay with Rosie being as loud as she can
she's always loved so you know to give
it um well I'd it's just so funny though
because this is this is a democratic
party this is what they're up against
right now they're trying to move to the
center because they know they keep
getting their butt kicked and they want
to win those voters that Trump won so
those white working-class and they're
not being allowed to because of crazies
like a rose you have taken over their
party and pull them to the left I mean
they're just saying we're going to be
open to the idea of someone who's you
know not Pro Sacrament abortion and
they're losing their minds want to start
a whole new party of just women by the
way women are not monolithic they're not
all pro-abortion so I mean I think it's
40 percent of women aren't for abortion
well almost half of women are pro-life
that support abortion and the numbers
get even even more interesting when you
break it down
I second trimester or light abortion
what have you how exact pulse is Amanda
right as the d-triple-c signaling that
it should back away from the sacramental
view of abortion it might not play in
Peoria yeah I think they realized that
it's been hazardous to them in the long
run I mean this is a litmus test that
was actually imposed upon by the
Clintons the last major pro-life
Democratic figure was governor robert
casey who was disinvited to speak at the
DNC in 1992 because of his pro-life
views and I think that after the
election of Trump and the fall of the
Rust Belt and Midwestern states sort of
going into the Republican Party I think
they see a serious problem on their
hands and there are a lot of pro-life
people that I know personally and out
there voicing themselves who identify
politically with the Democratic Party
but they just are very very
uncomfortable with their pro-abortion
views so I think it's starting to hit
them it also seems like a bad strategy
to keep killing the next generation of
your political activists second-last
rememory longer roaming I've done any
open border but yes that is what they
are you exactly yes yes yeah roaming if
Rosie stores an all women political
party will you be its nominee for
president and if so what will be your
first act in office well absolutely I
would you know join the party one at the
head of that movement because as we all
know the only thing women care about as
voters is abortion
that's right obviously just through
abortion data we will come a-runnin no
but seriously I have never understood
these left-wing feminists who try to
make abortion you know something that
all women should care about all the time
even if you're I know so I'm personally
pro-life but I know a lot of my friends
who are pro-choice and even for them
they understand that okay you know I may
or may not have an abortion throughout
my lifetime and hopefully you know Lord
willing it's never going to happen but
you know what I do do every day I do go
to work every day I do pay taxes every
day you know I do live in a society that
is influenced by immigration every day
maybe those are more important to me and
I you know when it comes to abortion it
I've actually been shamed as the one for
actually saying that you know I'm
pro-life but I don't know if it's
necessarily something I would you know
withdraw support from for
candidate if they came out into the
position I've been shamed by pro-life
women for not caring
sorry pro-choice woman for not caring
enough about the Thai shame I - for
shame roaming for shame right but I mean
what if shouldn't the point of abortions
be even if you're for for them - I don't
know half as little of them as possible
so Rosie O'Donnell just see none of
those people who I like I don't know the
sort of shout your abortion type of
feminist who's trying to you know
glorify it makes everyone wants one just
abortions you know on the street corner
and I just don't get Lena Dunham said
she's sorry she hasn't had an abortion
because she can't be a good ally for the
pro-choice movement and there is this
conflation - of abortion with women's
health so all of women's health and
abortion I I think someone else said it
but when you call up your grandmother
and you say hey grandma how you doing so
well you know my head hurts and you know
I walk as well but at least I still have
my right to have an abortion at least I
still have that that's not what I hear
my grandma okay you know what you have
to say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube
you can keep watching all of these great
panelists but only if you're not so
cheap you have to go to the daily
wire.com and subscribe it's only $10 a
month hundred dollars a year plus you
get the leftist tears tumblr the very
famous leftist tears tumblr keeps your
leftist two years hot or cold always
salty I will say I used my leftist ears
tumblr the other day I had iced coffee
in the morning I no joke I brought it in
at 7 a.m. or something like that by the
time I left at 6 p.m. in a hot office it
still had two ice cubes in it is a
really good tumblr perfect for such a
precious commodity as leftist ears go
there right now daily wire calm we'll
see you to talk about the news and the
mailbag
CNN's Jim Acosta recently got into a
heated exchange with White House aide
Stephen Miller over immigration the
Statue of Liberty says give me your
tired your poor your huddled masses
yearning to breathe free doesn't say
anything about speaking English or being
able to compute a computer programmer
aren't you trying to change what it
means to be an immigrant coming into
this country if you're telling them you
have to speak English I can't people
learn how to speak English when they get
here well first of all right now it's a
requirement that to be naturalized yet
it's being English so the notion that
speaking English wouldn't be a part of
immigration systems would be actually
very ahistorical secondly I don't want
to get off into a whole thing about
history here but the Statue of Liberty
is a symbol of Liberty enlightening the
world is a symbol of American liberty
lighting the world the poem that you're
referring to was added later it's not
actually part of the original Statue of
Liberty they're not evilly it's going to
be highly skilled they're not always
Jimmy Jimmy Jim I appreciate your speech
Jim I appreciate your speech so let's
let's talk about this let's talk about
this in nineteen Stephanie when we let
in 300,000 people a year with that
violating or not violating the Statue of
Liberty law of the land in nineteen in
the 1990s when it was half a million a
year was it violating or not violating
the Statue of Liberty law of the land
brutal hit goes on like that for about
seven minutes she couldn't cut any more
Paul I'm not familiar with international
law but did Stephen Miller technically
commit a war crime in his Smackdown of
Siena Oh
lock him up Michael lock him up lock him
up he triggered me he you know he I my
safe space was violated you know by the
idea the very idea that a government can
put up standards as to who they can let
in and let out of their borders is just
extremely offensive I mean I mean call
UN you know call the courts yes
absolutely lock roaming this issue
illegal immigration has been a major
issue for the last 10-15 years and
they've even accused those who want to
limit illegal immigration of bigotry but
the issue of limiting legal immigration
hasn't really been discussed very much
maybe the 90s maybe early 90s and now I
think it's clouded over with a great
sense that if you want to limit legal
immigration you're a bigot is it a
little ahjumma pinyin to say the country
should decide who comes in and who comes
out I mean legitimate opinion is such a
such a broad term right I think it's not
a racist opinion that is what I'm asking
is it racist is it bigoted to say we
don't want as many people from this
country we want more people from this
country and more people with these
degrees absolutely not actually you know
I'm I'm an immigrant myself I went to
the US as an international student for
college after that you know student visa
after that I got my opt visa than I did
the long arduous and expensive process
of applying for a green card you know I
I've been through the system and so you
know what really bothers me is when
people try to make it seem like caring
about immigration and wanting more
skilled immigrants is somehow like
racist or anti-immigrant it is neither
of those things and I think you know
immigrants who actually want the best of
United States and want to be you know
economic benefit to the United States
they should understand that hey you know
this is a this is a country where you
know welfare is already high you know
the number of unskilled laborers is
already perhaps higher than the number
of jobs for them so you know do do we
want to bring in more people who are
going to compete with the most
economically vulnerable people in the
society and you know the answer is no
and what's so funny is that the people
who are who are against any sort of
skills or means-testing for immigration
what they're actually in favor for is
bringing in people who are going to
again compete with people who are the
most vulnerable in American society so
you know if you actually care about the
American poor this is a great policy not
skill set if it were all roaming
Millennials coming across that Mexican
border I think we would all be Democrats
is that fair to say having had for today
Amanda a CNN reporter says that the poem
that he references is at the Statue of
Liberty but CNN is fake news so is it
possible that there's no poem at all
that's probably actually right but I was
going to wear that poetry was US law
whatever that whatever
yeah so whenever that happened like I
wish I knew that from the Obama years I
have I was you know I can write some
poetry um but it's just it's
unbelievable first of all Miller for
president even Miller is tremendous yeah
actually my favorite guy in that
administration oh just so smart and
dilated Acosta and this is this brings
up one other point that's kind of not
that relevant but there should not be
cameras and in these press briefings
because this is what happened this is
just more confirmation that we should
get those cameras how the granting at
showboating at some yeah it's ridiculous
but as opposed applying just regard to
policy this is actually really good
policy and this has to do a green card
so always the agricultural stuff they're
talking about it's like a different it's
not even it with this policies don't
even know if they understand is talking
about and when it comes to speaking
English it's on a point system so if you
don't speak English you can still get
any just don't get that point so he was
just wrong in so many levels
he must have gone lost in that beautiful
beautiful poetry sorry go to even
pretending to be a reporter and
objective at all at this point we were
you're literally an open border advocate
at this point right you're arguing that
they shouldn't need to speak English
like what how is that how's that turtles
of how is that reporting you know it's
funny I spent an afternoon one time with
Jim Acosta he came up to Yale because he
was covering a campaign that we were
running there and he wasn't like this he
was actually just kind of a TV newsman
he didn't seem to care at all about
politics I would say a little bit like
that Will Ferrel version of an anchorman
in that movie and now he's the biggest
political activist in the world who
knows what a trump derangement syndrome
must be hate the pain he got that's
right speaking of the presidential
politics and endless immigration Mark
Zuckerberg the CEO of Facebook has hired
Joel Benenson a Democratic pollster and
the chief strategist for Hillary 2016 2
fuel rumors that the suck will run for
president roaming if Mark Zuckerberg is
so smart why would he hire the
strategist of the worst campaign ever
well you know what I believe in multiple
intelligences right I think he's
probably you know gifted programmer so
like that
I think it's a social network or
whatever that movie was taught us
anything is that he may not be the best
read on people that's a very different
low Matic way of putting it
Amanda you may any so I go ahead gender
may not be on a spectrum but there's a
good chance he might be and I just like
the decisions he's made about this I
mean I think we found out 2016 slogan
that's the but that's the bumper sticker
slogan Amanda what do you think we can
look forward to in a Zuckerberg
administration other there won't be one
he commissioned is more charismatic than
Mark Zuckerberg a rock has a better
personality to the Mark Zuckerberg it's
going to be tough for him to win
anything he does have a ton of money and
a ton of power I understand that but he
has a ton of data later he knows
everything about us yeah yeah that's why
he's terrifying if he was if he actually
didn't win but I think luckily I think
we can bank on his terrible personality
in a zero charisma and he's not going to
go anywhere I know he's relying on
Hillary people has he not read shattered
I mean I think that no one be election
who knew big brother would be so DB by
probably everybody I guess Paul could
Zuckerberg defeat Trump does he stand a
chance or now oh no way no way I mean
it's pretty much just he represents
everything that Hillary represents in
many ways I mean he's a Silicon Valley
elitist he has no relationship
whatsoever to people in the Midwest or
especially Donald Trump's working-class
base a no I think he'd get creamed in
election I almost think he probably lose
in an even bigger landslide than a Larry
you heard it here first Vox Dei Vox
Populi Paul blah has settled it alright
you get out of here it's been great to
have you Amanda Presta Giacomo Rani
millennial and Paul blah now for the
first time ever we're going to do the
Michael Noel's show mailbag this is
great okay so some of these game in
tweets because we didn't have it set up
on the website yet so they'll be kind of
quick from Joel what our staff meetings
like when a papist a Jew and a
Protestant all have their own podcasts I
don't know but we have them in a bar
- lame joke Adrienne says can you give
me some tips for the SAT I'm assuming
you had in your perfect score thank you
very much for the compliment I can give
you some it's kind of funny so now the
SAT is two parts math and verbal and it
used to be two parts math and verbal but
when I took it for like five minutes
they had a third part and I did get a
perfect score on two parts on math and
verbal but I didn't get a perfect score
on the third part which was writing
which depending on how you look at it is
either ironic or manifest and obvious
they give it to my literary endeavors
from Madison Han that question was
intentionally left blank I think you
really get us here at the Michael Nolt
show great great question from Christian
mr. Noles first of all the show is great
thank you very much my question is
simply to satisfy my curiosity what
tweet is in the frame behind you it has
to be a good one to be in such a
beautiful gold frame I will tell you
what that tweet is it is the moment that
I knew we were living in a matrix esque
simulation it's the tweet from President
Trump endorsing my book a great book for
your reading enjoyment reasons to vote
for Democrats thank you president Trump
and thank you for the question this
question from BeerBelly
my name is beer shell fuel bell kenneth
e a ka beer belly
hello MK do you mind if I call you MK
that's what I imagined calling you if we
were close friends I'm in dire need of
help I look like a regular guy but in
reality I'm a transgender cross-dressing
homosexual female I've been happily
married for a long time but my wife has
decided she is now a transgender
cross-dressing homosexual male she still
looks the same but identifies as male
now this has created an obvious problem
of course I identify as female but she I
mean he now identifies as male and since
I'm out of a sexual and she I mean he is
homosexual we no longer have an intimate
relationship help me figure out what to
do I think I have to defer to the expert
on this from everyday feminism Reilly J
Dennis would you date a trans person
honestly think about it for a second
okay got your answer well if you said no
I'm sorry but that's pretty
discriminatory get over your bigotry
BeerBelly disgusting I can't believe
these people listen to our show dear
Mike list of Knowles from mark I'm
curious about my general day any general
dating and relationship advice you have
also did you win over your fiance's love
before or after you became world famous
as one of the greatest authors of all
time
how important is becoming famous
overnight in having a successful
relationship I'm very glad you asked
this question I think there's a lot of
misinformation out there about this I
did not win over sweet little Elise's
heart before I became famous I did
purchase her it was very expensive and I
think that if you're going to ground a
relationship on something that isn't as
fundamental as fleeting fame or a modest
windfall of money you're destined for
failure down the road so remember to
keep the important priorities at the top
thank you for your question from ASA
Hoffmann why are you Catholic instead of
Protestant because I want to go to
heaven of course and it's the one true
church I adds a good question there if
we do have here podcasts with a Jew a
Protestant and a Catholic I was an
atheist for a long time I was an atheist
or practical atheist until I was about
20 22 I was actually an atheist at the
time I was confirmed in the Catholic
Church which is why I chose Thomas as my
confirmation name I'm convinced of the
Catholic Church for a few reasons
I do think Peter is the rock on which
Christ built his church I do believe in
the primacy of Peter and the Petrine
line and I do think that Christ said to
Peter you have the kingdom the keys to
the kingdom of heaven whatever you bind
on earth will be bound in heaven
whatever you loose on earth will be
loosed in heaven
the Apostles would replace themselves
and and I do believe in a clergy in the
church the other reason which is I think
a little less wrote and heard of before
is is the idea that Christianity unlike
other world religions is a series of
facts it's not philosophy it's not
poetry exactly it's a series of facts a
man was born at a time in a place with
bones he wore clothes he did things on
earth he was killed he was resurrected
and so it seems he had specific apostles
it wasn't to sort of simply generalized
cereal spirit that he loosed on the
world he does talk to real people in
real time and so
seems perfectly reasonable to me that
that Messiah and that Lord would have a
real church with real buildings and real
artwork on the walls and a real clergy
that administers it so that's one of the
reasons and we can talk more about
religion later on that is all of the
mailbag questions that brings us to the
final thought the leftist project for
centuries has sought to perfect human
nature and each social experiment to
that end has failed and left varying
degrees of misery in its wake
scientific experiments to achieve that
goal may prove more effective but by no
means any more desirable Winston
Churchill warned of another scheme to
craft the master race that we might sink
into the abyss of a new Dark Age made
more sinister and perhaps more
protracted by the lights of perverted
science perhaps we should take a moment
to unfertile ASSA fee and culture before
we embrace a science with the potential
to destroy our humanity itself I'm
Michael Knowles this is a Michael Nolt
show no more shows this week tune back
in Monday and we'll see you then
[Music]